MINUTE.
I'M GOING TO START THIS WAY.
HERE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE OWED
AN APOLOGY FROM THE DEMOCRATS,
FROM THE PEOPLE COME UP FROM THE
RABBIT NEVER TRUMPERS TONIGHT.
FIRST, THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
>> I DON'T NEED THEM YEARLY
REPORT TO KNOW HE'S A TRAITOR.
>> THERE IS OUTRIGHT TREASON.
>> NOTHING SHORT OF TREASON THIS
BECAUSE IT'S A BETRAYAL OF THE
NATION.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD BE
INDICTED OR POSSIBLY FACE JAIL
TIME.
>> THIS IS A POTENTIALLY MORE
DANGEROUS SITUATION THAN
WATERGATE.
>> Laura: THESE DESTRUCTIVE
AND DEFAMATORY ALLEGATIONS WERE
BASED ON ERRONEOUS REPORTING,
ANONYMOUS SOURCES, LEAKS, AND
WHISPERS.
GOSSIPS.
BUT NOW WITH THE RELEASE OF THE
MUELLER REPORT, WE FIND IT WAS
ALL FALSE.
THE TRUMP FAMILY IS ALSO OWED AN
APOLOGY.
>> WHEN YOU GET INVOLVED WITH
THE ACTIONS OF HIS CHILDREN,
INCLUDING HIS DAUGHTER AND
SON-IN-LAW, WE ARE GETTING
CLOSER TO CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
>> IVANKA AND DON JR. ARE FULLY
IMPLICATED IN THE SELLING OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY FOR THE TRUMP
FAMILY GAIN.
>> WHAT YOU'LL SEE IS A MAN WHO
WANTS TO SHARE THE INNER
WORKINGS OF THE TRUMP CRIME
FAMILY.
>> Laura: NONE OF IT WAS TRUE.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR CERTAINLY
DESERVES AN APOLOGY.
>> HE WON'T GET HIS REPUTATION
BACK.
IT'S A SHOT.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA HAS
BEEN CORRUPTED.
>> HE'S LOST THE CREDIBILITY OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: ALL OF THEM.
NO WORDS FOR THE LIES, THE FALSE
ACCUSATIONS.
ARE THEY REALLY PAYING YOU
ENOUGH TO SAY THAT STUFF, GUYS?
TO THOSE WHO BRANDED THE
PRIME TIME HOSTS ON THIS NETWORK
AS STATE NEWS FOR DARING TO TELL
THE TRUTH, NOT JUST OUR TRUTH,
BUT THE TRUTH?
YOU OWE US AN APOLOGY.
>> FOX NEWS WILL BE AN
INCREDIBLE ASSET TO THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT ECHO CHAMBER IS GOING TO
ANNOUNCE THIS AS A VINDICATION.
>> WE TALK ABOUT THIS REVOLVING
DOOR.
THERE IS ALSO, OF COURSE, THE
ECHO CHAMBER.
WE KNOW HANNITY AND THE
PRESIDENT SPEAKS ALL THE TIME.
>> WE KNOW THAT HE OBSESSIVELY
WATCHES CABLE NEWS, REALLY
FOCUSING ON WHAT FOX NEWS IS
SAYING.
>> WHAT'S STAYED STUDIED FOR HIM
IS THE ECHO CHAMBER OF FOX NEWS.
>> Laura: NO WONDER THEY WERE
SO ANGRY TODAY.
IT WAS SEDITION, TREASON.
NOW...
FINALLY, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
OWED AN APOLOGY.
YOUR PRECIOUS TAX DOLLARS WERE
SPENT IN THE COUNTRIES FOCUS
DIVERTED TO INVESTIGATE A
PRESIDENT IN A
ON THE INNOCENT
FROM THE OUTSET BASED ON A DOSSI
FROM THE OUTSET BASED ON A DOSSR
FROM THE OUTSET BASED ON A DOSST
FROM THE OUTSET BASED ON A DOSSA
WAS FAKE AND PAID FOR BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
OTHER NETWORKS AND PRINT MEDIA
JOURNALIST TRICK VIEWERS AND
READERS INTO THINKING THAT THERE
PRESIDENT WAS A RUSSIAN STOOGE.
IT WAS ALL FALSE.
THIS WAS, PURE AND SIMPLE, AN
EFFORT TO UNDERMINE THE RESULTS
OF THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND
MANIPULATE PUBLIC OPINION.
EVERY EFFORT SHOULD BE MADE TO
INVESTIGATE THE ORIGINS AND
MOTIVATIONS OF THIS MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
IN THE COMING HOUR, WE WILL
SEPARATE FROM YOU LEGAL FACT
FROM FICTION ON THE MUELLER
REPORT.
WE WILL UNPACK THE POLITICAL
RAMIFICATIONS AND TELL YOU WHERE
WE GO FROM HERE.
AND IN JUST MOMENTS, WE WILL BE
JOINED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI.
NOW, FIRST BEFORE WE DIVE INTO
OUR EXPERT PANEL ANALYSIS, I
WANT TO GIVE YOU MY TAKEAWAYS
FROM THE MUELLER REPORT AND A
FEW THINGS THAT YOU NEED TO KEEP
IN MIND.
NUMBER ONE, THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS TEAM -- THEY WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND IN THEIR TRANSPARENCY IN
DEALING WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
THIS OPENNESS IN IT OF ITSELF
CUTS AGAINST ANY SUGGESTIONS YOU
MIGHT BE HEARING ON THE OTHER
CABLES OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
MY FRIENDS, IF TRUMP WANTED TO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE, HE WOULDN'T
HAVE WAIVED EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS,
IT'S THE DOCTRINE WHICH WOULD
HAVE SHIELDED MUCH OF THE
PRESIDENT'S INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS FROM
INVESTIGATORS AND FROM THE
PUBLIC.
BUT HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
IN FACT, I WOULD ARGUE --
REMEMBER, I WAS A FORMER
CRIMINAL DEFENSE LAWYER MYSELF,
CLERKED AT THE COURT.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S TEAM MAY HAVE GONE
OVERBOARD IN GIVING BARR MUCH
INFORMATION.
BUT ANYWAY, THIS DEMONSTRATES
THE PRESIDENT'S SUPREME
CONFIDENCE IN HIS OWN INNOCENCE
AT THE VERY BEGINNING.
HE HAD NOTHING TO HIDE.
BY THE WAY, THE TRANSPARENCY
EVEN EXTENDED TO THE RELEASE OF
THE REPORT ITSELF.
REMEMBER, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE GETTING MUCH MORE THAN IS
REQUIRED BY LAW.
AND BILL BARR?
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO A SYNOPSIS
OF THE REPORT.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO ANSWER PRESS
QUESTIONS THIS MORNING.
HE DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO RELEASE
THE REPORT TO THE PUBLIC OR TO
CONGRESS.
HIS ONLY OTHER OBLIGATION WAS TO
REPORT HIS FINDINGS TO CONGRESS.
THAT'S IT.
NUMBER TWO.
THE MEDIA COVERAGE OF THIS
RUSSIAN COLLUSION COORDINATION
CONSPIRACY STORY WAS AN EPIC
FAILURE FROM BEGINNING TO --
WELL, RIGHT ABOUT NOW.
REMEMBER THE TRUMP TOWER MEETING
IN JUNE OF 2016?
>> THE MEETING AT TRUMP TOWER
AND ALL THE LIES TO COVER UP
THAT MEETING, THAT DIRECT
EVIDENCE.
>> ALL OF THIS TALK ABOUT A
SECOND MEETING IS TRULY DAMNING.
>> THE TRUMP TOWER MEETING TRULY
CONVENED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
COLLUSION.
>> Laura: ALL FALSE.
IT TURNS OUT THAT MUELLER FOUND
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE THAT
PRESIDENTS BE A FIVE HAD ANY
ADVANCED KNOWLEDGE OF TOWER
MEETING, OR INVOLVED IN ANY WAY.
THEY ALSO DID NOT FIND, BY THE
WAY, THAT DONALD TRUMP JR. OR
ANY PICTURES OF PENS MEETING
VIOLATED THE LAW
INSTEAD, THE REPORT SAID, "THE
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT HAVE STRONG
EVIDENCE OF SARAH DISHES
BEHAVIOR OR EFFORT OF
CONCEALMENT AT THE TERM OF THE
JUNE 9TH MEETING."
WELL, THE STORY TURNED OUT TO BE
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL FARCE AND
THE
DUD.
BY THE WAY, CARTER PAGE?
HE WORKED FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AS A FOREIGN POLICY ADVISOR, AT
LEAST HIS NAME WAS ON AN
ADVISORY LIST FOR EIGHT MONTHS.
THE FBI, THOUGH, GOT A FISA
WARRANT TO SURVEY
SURVEIL PAGE FUNDED
BY TRUMP'S OPPONENTS.
>> CARTER PAGE WAS CONSPIRING
WITH RUSSIA IN WAYS THAT WERE
NEFARIOUS.
>> HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SURVEILLED.
>> IT WOULD NOT BE ENOUGH IF
THERE WAS PROBABLE CAUSE TO
BELIEVE THAT HE WAS ACTING AS AN
AGENT OF A FOREIGN POWER.
>> BUT IN THE END, MUELLER
WRITES ON PAGE 95 THAT HIS TEAM
"DID NOT ESTABLISH THAT PAGE
COORDINATED WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT AND HIS EFFORTS TO
INTERFERE WITH THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION."
REMEMBER, THERE WERE FOUR FISA
WARRANTS, ALL OF THEM INCOMPLET
INCOMPLETE.
ANOTHER ABUSE OF POWER BY THE
OBAMA FBI AND THE REST OF THE
DEEP STATE.
NUMBER THREE.
FOR ALL THAT WE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT, THE MUELLER REPORT IS
REALLY KIND OF JUST AN
INVITATION WHEN YOU READ IT AND
ESPECIALLY TOWARDS THE END FOR
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES TO
RUN THE BALL TO THE IMPEACHMENT
GOAL LINE.
THE RESISTANT MEDIA AND SOME
LEFT-WING DAMS ARE NOW HANGING
THERE IMPEACHMENT HOPES ON
THE FACT THAT MUELLER DID NOT
SPECIFICALLY EXONERATE TRUMP ON
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
TODAY, THEY WERE GRASPING AT
MORE STRAWS AND MAKING A LOT OF
TRUMP'S REACTION TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL WHEN HE SAID, MY GOD,
THIS IS TERRIBLE.
THIS IS THE END OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
I AM -- WELL BLANKED.
THE PRESS CLAIMS THAT'S THE
REACTION OF A GUILTY MAN.
>> THIS IS THE END OF MY
PRESIDENCY, I AM ASKEDDED.
HE SLUMPED
BACK IN HIS CHAIR AND SAID THIS
IS TERRIBLE, THIS IS THE END OF
MY PRESIDENCY, I AM F'ED.
>> ALL THIS STUFF IN HERE.
IS THAT NOT ENOUGH?
>> Laura: WHEN TRUMP SAID IT
WAS THE END OF MY PRESIDENCY,
IT'S BECAUSE HE BELIEVED HE WAS
A MAN UNFAIRLY ACCUSED.
AND HE WAS ENRAGED OVER THE FACT
THAT HIS ENTIRE AGENDA WOULD BE
STYMIED, AND HIS PRESIDENCY
MIRED IN YEARS OF INVESTIGATION.
HE UNDERSTOOD THAT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
I DON'T BLAME HIM FOR BEING THAT
MAD.
CERTAINLY ISN'T ANY EVIDENCE OF
AN INTENT TO OBSTRUCT.
ANYONE WHO ARGUES DIFFERENTLY
SHOULD HAVE THEIR LAW LICENSE
REVOKED OR NOT COMMENTING ON
THESE MATTERS ON TELEVISION.
GO TO SOMETHING ELSE.
MUELLER'S FINDINGS CONVICT TRUMP
OF OBSTRUCTION EVEN THOUGH
MUELLER STATED HE COULD NOT DRAW
SUCH A CONCLUSION.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAYS ON PAGE
EIGHT OF VOLUME TWO.
"UNLIKE CASES IN WHICH A SUBJECT
ENGAGES IN OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE TO COVER UP A CRIME, THE
EVIDENCE WE CONTAINED DID NOT
ESTABLISH THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
INVOLVED IN AN UNDERLYING CRIME
RELATED TO RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE,
ALTHOUGH THE OBSTRUCTION
STATUTES DO NOT REQUIRE PROOF OF
SUCH A CRIME, THE ABSENCE OF
THAT EVIDENCE AFFECTS THE
ANALYSIS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
INTENT AND REQUIRES
CONSIDERATION OF OTHER POSSIBLE
MOTIVES FOR HIS CONDUCT,
JUDGMENTS ABOUT THE NATURE OF
THE PRESIDENT'S MOTIVE DURING
EACH PHASE WOULD YOU BE INFORMED
BY THE TOTALITY OF THE EVIDENCE.
."
BARR AND THE LEGAL TEAM OF DOJ
DID EXAMINE THE TOTALITY OF
EVIDENCE, AND EVEN USED
MUELLER'S LEGAL FRAMEWORK TO
ANALYZE HIS FINDINGS ON
OBSTRUCTION.
AFTER TWO YEARS AND $30 MILLION,
TAXPAYER MONEY, THE DEMOCRATS
WILL NOT EXCEPT THAT ACCEPT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S FINDINGS.
BARR'S FINDINGS.
THEY PLAN TO RELITIGATE THE
ENTIRE DRAMA, ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER, THEY ARE GOING TO TRY
TO DO IT FROM NOW UNTIL 2020.
BUT WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATING IS HOW THIS FARCE
BEGAN.
AND WHO WAS RESPONSIBLE.
WHAT THEIR MOTIVES WERE.
THE SURVEILLANCE OF INNOCENT
AMERICANS, THE DECEPTION OF THE
FIRES OF COURT APPLICATION, THE
ILLEGAL LEAKING OF GOVERNMENT
INFORMATION, AND THE ENTIRE
MUELLER PROBES WERE NEVER
ABOUT HOLDING A PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE.